je pense que la montagne n'est pas un
endroit pour faire du sport
ouais je suis un peu énervé là je vous
dis ça parce que cet été on m'a obligé à
faire une
randonnée des gens qui ont déjà fait ça
oui j'ai marché 7h pour un d'une
montagne j'ai mis plus de temps pour
aller en haut de la montagne que pour
partir en vacances à la
montagne je crois que le guide était un
peu particulier en plus qu'on était en
bas il m'a dit tu vas voir Paul en haut
c'est super beau
on est arrivé en
haut il m'a dit tu as vu en bas c'est
super
beau je dis ben je sais on y était tout
à
l'heure pourquoi on n'est pas resté
là-bas du
coup tu veux que je te mette toi dans
les yeux c'est ça